REPUBLICANS GOING FORWARD ON
IMMIGRATION.
WE HAVE THAT AND SO MUCH MORE ON
TOLD YOU IS COMING.
TONIGHT IT'S IN FULL MOTION.
EVERYTHING WE HAVE REPORTED THE
LAST YEAR AND THE MEDIA HAS
IGNORED THE PAST YEAR IS NOW
UNCOVERED.
WE HAVE SO MUCH INFORMATION.
WE WILL GO THROUGH IT SLOWLY FOR
EVERYONE TO GET IT PLEASE STAY
WITH US.
IT WILL TAKE YOUR BREATH AWAY.
JEFF SESSIONS IS REVEALING THERE
ARE MORE THAN 50,000 TEXT
LISA PAGE THIS.
IS SIGNIFICANT.
PREVIOUS REPORTING PUT TEXT
MESSAGES AT TEN THOUSAND.
SESSIONS IS VOWING TONIGHT TO
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF THE MISSING
TEXT MESSAGES WHICH BEGINNING TO
LOOK MORE AND MORE LIKE A FBI
SCANDAL.
IT TIES INTO EVERYTHING WE HAVE
MONTHS OF TEXT MESSAGES BETWEEN
THE TRUMP HATING LOVERS, STRZOK
AND PAGE.
THEY HAVE CONVENIENTLY
DISAPPEARED.
I DON'T MAKE THIS UP.
THE MESSAGES THE FBI CLAIMS TO
TIME IN THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
HERE IS WHAT HAPPENED.
DURING THAT FIVE MONTHS THIS.
IS FROM DECEMBER 14th, 2016 TO
MAY 17, 2017.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CLAIMED HE WAS
WIRETAPPED AT TRUMP TOWERS.
WE DON'T HAVE WHAT THEY WERE
THE RUSSIAN PHONY DOSSIER TO GET
THE FILING AGAINST THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
JANUARY 24th NOW LIEUTENANT
GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN IS
INTERVIEWED BY THE FBI.
I HOPE FLYNN'S ATTORNEYS ARE
WATCHING TONIGHT.
CLEAR HE DESPISES ALL THINGS
DONALD TRUMP.
HE OVERSAW THE INTERVIEW.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER HOW FARE
WOULD STRZOK BE.
HE HAD NO PROBLEM BEING INVOLVED
IN THAT INVESTIGATION OR ANY
OTHERS HE'S INVOLVED IN.
THE GUY SHOULDN'T HAVE A JOB.
AS I SAID LAST FRIDAY HE SHOULD
BE FIRED.
HE SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED.
THEN WE GO TO MAY ET, JAMES
COMEY IS FIRED.
MAY 17th, ROBERT MUELLER IS
NAMED SPECIAL COUNCIL.
THE MESSAGES ARE MISSING FROM
THAT ENTIRE TIME PERIOD.
THE MOST CRITICAL TIME.
ROBERT MUELLER WAS APPOINTED
SPECIAL COUNCIL.
NOW STRZOK AND PAGE R-LT KEY
PLAYERS IN ALL WE'RE UNCOVERING.
ARE WE SUPPOSE TO BELIEVE THE
FBI SIMPLY LOST TEXT MESSAGES
FROM THAT IMPORTANT TIME FRAME.
THIS IS LIKE WATERGATE AND FAR
WORST.
REMEMBER THE 18 AND A HALF
MINUTE GAP IN THE WHITE HOUSE
TAPES THIS.
WREAKS OF LAW BREAKING.
WREAKS OF CONSPIRACY.
BY THE WAY THE COVER UP IS
ALWAYS WORST THEN THE CRIME.
THAT'S WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE TO ME
TONIGHT.
THE PUGH OJ ARE TRYING TO
EXPLAIN IT AWAY.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT THE FBI
FIVE PHONES DIDN'T CAPTURE
MESSAGES DURING THAT PERIOD.
HOLD ON WE'RE BLAMING SAMSUNG?
COLLECTION ABILITIES.
BLAME SAMSUNG, SAMSUNG?
WHERE ARE THE PHONES TONIGHT.
INSTEAD OF MAKING EXCUSES.
THE FBI HAVE YOU BROUGHT IN YOUR
BEST EXPERTS TO ANALYZE THE
PHONES.
BY THE WAY IF YOU CAN'T GET THE
MESSAGES YOU NEED TO CALL
SAMSUNG.
MAYBE THEY WILL HELP YOU.
IF THE FBI DOESN'T WANT TO DO
THAT WE CAN ONLY DRAW THE
CONCLUSION THE FBI IS CLEARLY
HIDING SOMETHING IN THIS VERY
CRUCIAL TIME PERIOD AND TIME
LINE WE'RE TALKING  ABOUT.
REMEMBER LOIS LEARNER, ANOTHER
E-MAIL SCANDAL.
33,000 DELETED E-MAILS
SUBPOENAED BY CONGRESS.
TO MAKE SURE THEY WERE ERASED
AND NEVER RETURNED AGAIN CLINTON
ACID WASHED THE HARD DRIVES TO
GET RID OF THEM.
NO TRACE OF THEM.
THE E-MAILS UNDER CONGRESSIONAL
SUBPOENA. THEN A CLINTON AID
TOOK THE BLACKBERRIES AND MOBILE
DEVICES AND SMASHED THEM WITH A
HAMMER.
THE FEW REMAINING CELLPHONES
TURNED OVER TO THE FBI HAD NO
SIM CARDS.
LOOK AT THE HEADLINES.
FBI AGREED TO DESTROY LAP TOPS
WHY WOULD THE FBI AGREE TO
DESTROY EVIDENCE?
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
ACCORDING TO THE SAME REPORTING
THE SERVER WAS PUBLIC.
SO THE FBI COULDN'T LOOK AT
POSSIBLE OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE
BY CLINTON AND AIDES.
IT'S OBVIOUS THAT HAPPENED.
THEN HERE, THE WASHINGTON POST
REPORTS IMMUNITY DEALS STOP
INVESTIGATION OF BLEACH BIT USE
IN THE CLINTON E-MAIL CASE.
CLINTON DESTROYED EVIDENCE AND
THEY DIDN'T INVESTIGATE.
INSTEAD OF COMING CLEAN AND
ADMITTING WHAT SHE WAS DOING,
UNSECURED E-MAIL SERVER IN A MOM
AND POP SHOP BATHROOM CLOSET.
FIVE FOREIGN INTELLIGENT
AGENCIES GOT ACCESS TO THIS,
LOOK.
OF STATE ALLOWED ME TO USE MY
E-MAIL FOR WORK.
THAT'S UNDISPUTED.
IT WAS CLEARLY NOT THE BEST
CHOICE.
I TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THAT
DECISION.
I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE EASIER TO
CARRY JUST ONE DEVICE FOR MY
WORK AND PERSONAL E-MAILS
INSTEAD OF TWO.
>> iPHONE OR ANDROID.
[LAUGHING]
>> iPHONE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> OKAY.
IN FULL DISCLOSURE.
>> BLACKBERRY.
>> AND A BLACKBERRY.
I HAVE A, YOU KNOW iPAD MINI.
iPAD, iPHONE AND BLACKBERRY
>> DID YOU WIPE IT?
>> WITH A CLOTH OR SOMETHING?
NO.
>> BY THE WAY YOU MAY OF SEEN I
LAUNCHED A SNAPCHAT ACCOUNT.
I LOVE IT.
THOSE MESSAGES DISAPPEAR ALL BY
THEMSELVES.
>> REALLY YOU ARE JOKING ABOUT
IT.
SHE BROKE THE LAW.
WE SNOW SHE
WE KNOW SHE DIDN'T TAKE CARE OF
CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET
INFORMATION.
AND IT'S SIMPLE THE FBI LET HER
OFF THE HOOK.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT IN A
SEC.
WE HAVE NEW INFORMATION THIS.
IS PART OF A PATTERN FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
LOIS LEARNER, IRS TARGETING
E-MAILS AND THE OFFICIAL LEADING
THE CHARGE AND UNFAIRLY GOING
LOST BECAUSE OF A SYSTEM CRASH.
EVERY TIME THE WALLS ARE CLOSING
IN ON THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS KEY EVIDENCE JUST
DISAPPEARS.
THEY FOUND IT TWO YEARS LATER IN
THE CASE.
WHEN IT KEEPS HAPPENING IT'S NOT
A COINCIDENCE.
IT'S CALLED OBSTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE.
THIS ARE SEVERAL OTHER WRINKLES
IN THE STORY.
REMEMBER DEBBIE SCHULTZ.
HE HAD SMASHED HARD DRIVES.
THEY SAID IT DIDN'T.
NEW INFORMATION FROM PETER
STRZOK AND PAGE THEY BOTH OF
THEM AND ADD THE FORMER ATTORNEY
GENERAL, LORETTA LYNCH, KNEW
CLINTON WOULDN'T BE PROSECUTED
IN THE E-MAIL INVESTIGATION.
LET'S GIVE YOU THE BACK STORY.
IN MAY COMEY, STRZOK AND OTHER
OFFICIALS WERE DRAFTING THE
OTHER KEY WITNESSES.
EXONERATION BEFORE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT'S RIGGED AND THE FIX WAS
IN.
YOU HAVE FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
TALKING  ABOUT GRAND CHILDREN
FOR 40 MINUTES AT THE END OF
JUNE.
LYNCH CALLED COMEY AND HAD THE
COMEY FOLLOWED HER ORDERS TO THE
LETTER.
THEN JUST DAYS LATER WHEN LYNCH
SAID SHE WOULD STEP AWAY FROM
THE E-MAIL INVESTIGATION.
SHE SAID SHE WOULD ACCEPT THE
FBIs CONCLUSION.
STRZOK TEXTED PAGE.
LOOK AT THIS.
TIMING LOOKS LIKE HELL.
YES, PAGE AWFUL TIMING.
IT'S A PROFILE ENCOURAGE SINCE
STRZOK AND PAGE TALKING ABOUT
THE INSURANCE POLICY IN CASE
DONALD TRUMP BECAME PRESIDENT.
THE FIX WAS IN.
THIS WAS RIGGED.
EXONERATION WITH NO
INVESTIGATION.
YOU HAVE STRZOK, PAGE AND LYNCH
THEY WROTE THE EXONERATION EARLY
ON.
IF LISA PAGE NEW THAT MEANS HER
BOSS KNEW.
WE THINK STRZOK AND PAGE WERE
TALKING TOO IN THE "INSURANCE"
TEXT MESSAGE.
KNOWING THAT CLINTON WOULD GO G.
FREE.
WHAT DID ROSEN STEIN KNOW AND
KNOW IT?
HE HAS A LOT OF QUESTIONS TO
START ANSWERING.
COUNTRY KNEW.
I GATHER SOMEONE IN THE OBAMA
WHITE HOUSE ALSO KNEW THE FIX
YOU PUT THE FIX IN AND SHE'S IN
THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
IF SHE GETS INDICTED THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THEY THOUGHT THEY KNEW BETTER
AND SAVED HILLARY.
THEY THOUGHT SHE WOULD WIN AND
YOU THINK WATER GATE WAS A BIG
SCANDAL?
THIS IS WATER GATE ON STEROIDS
AND HUMAN GROWTH HORMONES AT
LEVELS THAT WOULD KILL THE
AVERAGE PERSON.
TO TOP IT OFF THERE IS MORE
INFORMATION, NEW TEXT MESSAGE
EXONERATION LETTER.
THEY TALKED OF CLINTON ON THE
TERRITORY OF A HOSTILE COUNTRY.
REMOVED ENTIRELY.
OBAMA HAD TO KNOW CLINTON WAS
USING A PRIVATE E-MAIL SERVER.
WE HAVE NEW INFORMATION ABOUT
THE CLASSIFIED FOUR PAGE MEMO
DETAILING THE MASSIVE ABUSES
AGAINST THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS BECOMING THE BIGGEST
SCANDAL IN AMERICAN HISTORY,
MODERN AMERICAN HISTORY.
ARE SHOCKING.
JAW DROPPING, ALARMING, PEOPLE
WILL GO TO JAIL, FOX NEWS IS
REPORTING TONIGHT THAT RELEASING
THE MEMO TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE COULD TAKE UP TO 19
CONGRESSIONAL BUSINESS DAY IT'S
THE PROCEDURES ARE FOLLOWED.
THAT MEANS WE DON'T GET TO SEE
THE MEMO.
YOU DON'T GET TO SEE THE MEMO
UNTIL AT LEAST THE MIDDLE OF
MARCH.
TONIGHT WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU
KEEP APPLYING PRESSURE.
DEMAND THAT THE PUBLIC SEE THE
MEMO.
RELEASE THE MEMO.
YOU NEED TO SEE THE TRUTH.
YOU NEED TO KNOW ABOUT THIS
MASSIVE ABUSE OF POWER.
THEY'RE TRAMPLING ON THE
FOR PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
SHE FIXED THE PRIMARY.
HAD COMEY STRUCK AND APPARENTLY
LORETTA LYNCH APPARENTLY FIXING
HER CASE.
AND THEN THE PHONY DOSSIER TO
FIX THE ELECTION.
WHY NOT.
THEN THEY USE IT IN A EFFORT TO
SPY ON AN OPPOSITION CANDIDATE
IN A A ELECTION YEAR, PRESIDENT
ELECT AND HIS TEAM.
WE NEED TO SEE THIS MEMO.
(202)224-3121.
TELL YOUR MEMBER WE ARE OF
CONGRESS TO RELEASE THE MEMO.
A TON OF INFORMATION TONIGHT.
LET ME SUM UP WHAT THIS ALL
MEANS.
CLINTON FIXED THE PRIMARY
AGAINST BERNIE.
STRUCK COMEY.
APPARENTLY LORETTA LINN SKP-FP
EXONERATED HILLARY WITHOUT
INTERVIEWING HER OR THE KEY
PEOPLE IN THE E-MAIL SERVER
SCANNED AFPLT THE FIX WAS IN.
IT WAS RIGGED.
THEY INFLUENCED THE GENERAL.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR RUSSIAN LIES
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THE FIX WAS IN THERE.
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WEAPONNIZED TO TARGET THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
STRZOK AND HIS MISTRESS TALKING
ABOUT A KEY INSURANCE POLICY AND
KEY TEXT MESSAGES ARE IN.
THE FIX IS.
IN WORST THAN WATERGATE.
AN ABUSE OF POWER.
THESE PEOPLE NEED TO BE FIRED
AND INVESTIGATED.
MORE INVESTIGATED.
NOT TALKING RANK AND FILE
MEMBERS IN THE FBI THAT DO GREAT
WORK.
IN THE DEEP STATE OF THE FBI AND
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
IF ROBERT MUELLER IF YOU'RE
WATCHING, I'M SURE YOU ARE.
I'M SURE YOUR CORRUPT TEAM OF
OBAMA, HILLARY CLINTON DEEP
STATE WITCH HUNTERS ARE
WATCHING.
THIS WITCH HUNT NEEDS TO BE SHUT
DOWN.
YOU CLEARLY HAVE STACKED THE
DECK AGAINST AND STARTED WITH A
BIAS INVESTIGATION AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
FINALLY TO THE THE GOVERNMENT
SHUT DOWN IS OVER.
PRESIDENT JUST SIGNED A